la haute côte d'or un territoire de 15
mille habitants où plusieurs activités
économiques existent comme la filière
bois la filière pierre l'agriculture le
commerce et les services
le projet d'un onzième parc national
inquiète les acteurs économiques dans la
filière pierre par exemple la pierre de
bourgogne ce matériau noble demeure très
demandé la charte du parc impose des
zones d'exclusion la prospection de la
pierre se verrait freiner la crainte
c'est l'accès à la ressource soit encore
plus compliqué qu'il n'est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a des législations qui
sont drastiques et c'est normal pour
pouvoir ouvrir une carrière puisqu'on et
installations classées pour la
protection de l'environnement mais on a
on a entre guillemets par besoin d'une
couche supplémentaire de réglementation
la filière doit répondre à une demande
croissante en pierre de bourgogne et
pour cela la prospection et permanente
une carrière a une durée de vie limitée
il faut donc trouver de nouveaux
gisements le parc national apparaît
alors comme un obstacle pour accéder à
la ressource pour le bois aussi les
choses risquent de se compliquer les
chaînes du châtillonnais sont très
prisés par exemple pour la fabrication
de fûts et de tonneaux alors que le
marché du bois en france traverse déjà
une crise d'approvisionnement me fais
pas de souci pour les quelques années
moi qui me reste à travailler mais les
projets que j'avais prévu pour la
continuité de nos entreprises sont un
peu on suspend parce que les gens ne
veulent pas s'engager fermement sur un
secteur où l'approvisionnement va être
complètement flou
les chefs d'entreprise du châtillonnais
ont une douzaine de propositions
concrètes pour le maintien et le
développement de l'activité économique
mais pour l'instant leurs demandes sont
restées sans réponse évidemment on n'est
pas content parce que oui pour nous il
n'y a pas de parks en développement
économique et le développement
économique tout du moins dans sa version
classique à la fois pour les entreprises
existantes mais pour les entreprises
aussi à créer innovante est absent dans
ses grandes lignes de cette charte donc
ça ne me convient pas les entreprises du
châtillonnais souhaite bien faire
entendre leur voix face au projet de
parc national
il s'estime absent du débat pour
l'instant c'est zéro réponse
même après une relance qui a été fait il
ya déjà un mois nous n'avons pas de
réponse c'est inadmissible on peut pas
considérer que l'économie fait partie de
la charrette lorsqu'on ne répondent même
pas à nos demandes façon c'est pas
concevable l'assemblée générale du
groupement d'intérêt public se tient
demain en haute-marne la charte du parc
national présenté dans sa troisième
version pourrait être signé
[Musique]